that ever happened to me i don't know
what i would do
our community shaken after the death of
a ten-year-old boy apparently shot and
killed by his 14-year-old brother thanks
for joining us here at six i'm david
charns and i'm vanessa murphy brian and
denise are off tonight henderson police
tell us the slain 10-year-old's name is
dylan houston
the shooting happened yesterday morning
in a home near horizon ridge parkway and
south gibson road
in the coroner's office telling us
houston died later in the day his older
brother now in custody charged with one
count of manslaughter tonight this case
raising a lot of questions about how
that teenager got his hands on that gun
in the first place experts say firearms
should always be locked away when at
home mary jane belliesa has more with
safety reminders
[Music]
many families have a gun in the home as
a means for sport or protection but
experts i spoke with say that also means
protecting the ones you love with
education on gun safety
this seems like a tragic accident but of
course we need to prevent even just one
death of a child's loss is too much
especially in clark county for retired
henderson police officer david colemeyer
he says it takes more than just hiding
near guns to keep kids safe it's all
about education too he says to keep
firearms out of sight and locked away
this also includes hiding bullets in a
separate location as the father of three
young kids he says it's important to
teach your children what to do if they
find a gun and the consequences of what
could happen if they pick it up if you
see a firearm not to touch it to tell a
parent or even maybe notify the police
calling 911 the emergency number or
calling 311 the non-emergency you know
maybe going on to google and you know
showing firearms or looking up some
different stories and using it as a
reference point that children have died
you should back away
and and
call you and tell your moms or dads
whoever's watching you you should call
the police when
when
before someone touches a gun kohlmeyer
says it's also best to have these
conversations with others if your child
is visiting a friend's home ask the
adults whether they have guns and if so
whether these are securely and safely
stored make sure you know your child's
friend and the friend's parents before
your child goes to their home and always
make sure a trusted adult will be at the
house while your child is visiting cole
meyer says be sure to go over and think
about all the aspects when considering
buying a gun in your household or if you
already own a gun you can also buy gun
locks online at we're at a gun shop
reporting in the newsroom mary jane
valeza live local now